Tom had a really hard time separating
himself from his role in the crowded
room he said I was seeing myself in him
but in my personal life Tom had an
especially tough time with this because
his character was based on American
criminal Billy Milligan the first person
to be found guilty for reasons of
insanity you can see why Tom said it had
him exploring certain emotions that I
have definitely never experienced before
Tom even had a meltdown at home when
they were in the middle of filming and
he says that he thought I need to shave
my head because I need to get rid of
this character he didn't do it but you
can tell the kind of stress he was under
Tom said I'm no stranger to the physical
aspects of the job doing the whole
action movie thing but the mental aspect
it really beat me up and it took a long
time for me to recover afterwards to
sort of get back reality this role led
to him taking a year off from acting to
focus on his mental health which says a
lot